[Music]
all right guys we are talking about
another Sony TV in the house today this
is their Flagship series The
x95k I have it in the 65 inch variant
there's an 85 inch variant as well now
previously I reviewed the 880k OLED
panel very good for the price point had
the Bravia camera on top of it we talked
about that as well if you haven't seen
that video do check it out but how good
is this mini LED panel versus the OLED
and which one would I go for let's talk
about it right now okay guys before we
kick things off I am not paid or
sponsored by Sony Singapore they load me
the TV it goes right back to them after
this review let's get on to talking
about this bad boy first and foremost
mini LED versus OLED now there is going
to be an argument out there OLED is
going to be more Punchy more vibrant
more contrasty beautiful deep rich
blacks a lot of you out there that are
used to using your IMAX or PC see the
eye displays whatever will be used to
the OLED look the mini LED is more
nuanced for a lot of people out there
they may not like it because it's not
even when it's completely black there's
going to be a little bit of a shift here
and there when it's a great card for
that matter but what you get with mini
LED that you don't get with OLED is the
more the nuances the nice roll off on
the highlights and the Shadows a much
more natural looking image and for some
people out there they may not notice it
and for others they will depending on
the content that you're watching if
you're watching Youtube primarily you
probably won't care
but if you're watching movies you're
watching Cinema you're watching
something where they shoot in lower
light situations and you want to see
that gradualness come into play that's
where mini LED Will Shine versus OLED
now for me personally I do tend to
prefer more OLED displays especially for
the price point and for the overall look
but I can appreciate mini LED and that's
why for the x95k I do like it but I do
think I have seen the new version of
this TV that was recently announced by
Sony as well and they have improved on
it a little bit more I do think though
for the cinema files I would definitely
recommend mini LED for the gamers for
the people that like YouTube content
that like that kind of that kind of
crunchy more contrasty look to your
image definitely go for OLED it's less
expensive and you're still going to get
the same process of the same performance
that you're getting out of this uh this
x95k but just a little bit of a
different image quality now in terms of
the menu system and everything else it's
exactly the same as the 880k which is
great I think Sony system works really
well it's very easy to access your quick
menus to drop down from Vivid to
cinematic to IMAX mode all that is there
that we did on the 880k it does carry
over into this you can also use the
Bravia cam as well if you want to
integrate that into your system again
the Bravia cam may turn off some people
because of the Privacy issue but Sony's
really sort of nipped out in the bud so
I don't think it's a big issue at all
but it's really about the image quality
now the speakers that come out of this
are also fantastic as well but again are
you going to use your speakers that are
out of the TV or are you going to have a
sound bar or a home theater system if I
was to get a TV like this and I'm going
to invest this kind of money into a TV
set like this I would definitely
recommend getting a soundbar I got the
Bose soundbar here Sony makes some great
speakers as well so to each their own
but you want that Cinema experience
invest a little bit more into a really
good sound system I know Sony makes some
wireless speakers that sound fantastic I
got the bows as I mentioned but you know
what I mean it's just whatever works for
you best in terms of your budget in
terms of your preference so let's talk
about some of the nuances on this TV in
terms of ports
I don't like where the ports are at it's
a little bit tough especially if you do
not have a mounting system that you can
pull the TV out from now for me here I
don't have that it's against the wall
with the a80k everything was on the side
it was easy easily accessible with my
hand now this one is underneath and on
the side
or it's in the back into the side it's
really a little bit cumbersome and I
don't know why Sony did that because if
you're going to make it a lot easier for
your less expensive TV you should make
it even more easier for your most
expensive TV I had to use my smartphone
and had to use it the camera as a mirror
so I could sort of see where I'm
plugging things in I shouldn't have to
do that with the seven eight thousand
dollar TV set now this may be improved
in the latest version we have not seen
that version yet here but I'm using the
previous which most of you will probably
get because it's on special right now
it's a very good price point but it's
something to point out now you have your
HDMI arcs for your sound system that
port's there you know your 4K 120 all
that's built into this TV I got a
PlayStation 5 here it works beautifully
on this no issues at all with that in
terms of the menu system the menu system
is very easy from Sony I definitely do
appreciate this if you have the quick
mini system that shows up at the bottom
of the screen when you're going to
access it through and through whatever
if you're even watching a movie or
Netflix or YouTube you can access it
right away if you want to change from
Vivid to cinematic from your sound
system you can do all that there it Sony
does a great job with that and I
appreciate that they don't make it
cumbersome some TV's out there you need
a degree to figure it out not with Sony
you just need to play around with it for
about five minutes and you kind of
figure out how it works outside of that
though the TV is a panel there's not
it's really non-descript there's nothing
that makes you go wow this is a
beautiful design it just is all
displayed borders are minimal It's
relatively thin it looks like a TV
it is what it is you know what I mean
but again it's the image quality that
comes out from it and that's what I'm
talking about with the mini LED versus
the OLED anyway before we go to our
final thoughts on this beautiful
x95k TV here's a message from our
sponsor this video is brought to you by
Asus check out the Asus Zenbook 14x OLED
Space Edition commemorating the 25th
anniversary of the first Asus laptop
sent into space Not only does it offer a
space exclusive design but it's even
worthy of going where no man has gone
before with its space grade durability
it even comes with a 3.5 inch OLED
companion Zen Vision display and you
will have a ball of a time taking
interviews with a 16 by 10 4K OLED Nano
Edge Pantone validated 14 inch display
but overall my final thoughts on this is
I appreciate it I understand why the
benefit of mini LED is there
but for I think most of you out there
OLED will be more than enough OLED
technology has improved so much so and
the prices come down so much that I
don't see
why I would justify the price point of
this TV versus an a80k now there's other
TVs as well in Sony's lineup but to me I
just don't really see it unless you're a
cinema file and you'll really appreciate
those nuances and the highlights and the
Shadows then definitely get otherwise
save some money invest in some speakers
and get a really badass theater home
system and you're going to appreciate it
alright guys those are my thoughts on
the x95k I know some of you out there
may disagree with me if you do let me
know in the comment section below if you
like this review check out more of our
TV reviews right here